hello everyone and welcome to the
twelfth and final game of the 2018 World
Chess Championship match between Magnus
Carlsen and Fabiana Khurana if you are
just tuning in to this channel or
perhaps even to this match then the
previous eleven games have been drawn
the result is five and a half to five
and a half and if we get another draw
then it will not be the final game it
will be the final in classical time
format but then we are going into the
playoffs we already mentioned how that
works so let's check it out it's very
interesting Caruana has the white pieces
so basically if you disregard the
previous 11 games Caruana just needs a
win against crossing with the white
pieces to become world champion sounds
like a sounds like a very easy task but
you know you are playing against the
world champion and Carlsen of course he
would like to win in classical time
format but then again everyone in the
world is of an opinion that the
tiebreaks
will definitely go in his favor as he is
the favorite in well pretty much every
time format but especially in faster
time controls so before we check out the
actual game let's check a couple of
photos again compliments of niki riga a
link to her social links will be in the
description below so feel free to check
out some of her other work now let's dig
in here you can see a nice photo of
course--and arriving corwin are still
not at the board and you can see you
know next - how many lenses Crossan has
to walk just to get his chair where he's
about to start his game and here we have
Caruana he arrives at the game against
we have a semi diagonal handshake still
you can see that the players are really
trying not to have any eye contact
whatsoever you just you want to play
against the position not at all
imagine that you're actually playing
against a person I guess that's the idea
here and we also have a very nice
close-up of course and so far at least
not to my knowledge across and did not
play the little joke you know push the
pawn to c6 and only then push it all the
way to c5 like McHale called it against
Bobby Fischer the first time they met
but you know he might he might do it
in in some other tournament and he would
have a very nice photo of Caruana just
showing it because it's a very nice
photo so there we have it let's check
out this game again we have a line that
was already played a lot of times in
this world chess championship match
every game for one started with e4 so
here he starts with e4 once again and in
the previous video I mentioned that 11
draws it this is the most that appeared
so far in a World Championship match and
then a lot of you said yeah but Casper
versus Karpov had 17 draws but that was
in the older time format where at the
match could last indefinitely until one
of the players scored six and a half
points here the match can only last for
12 classical game so that format will
not be will not ever be broken at least
and not until the rules are changed but
yes of course in that regard you are
corrected the longest
draw streak in a row is 17 draws in a
magical power of Karpov but returning
here we have c5 the Sicilian defense by
Carlsen tonight at 396 d4 exactly the
same as was already played Knight
captures Knight f6 Knight c3 e5 we have
Knight to d5 the last variation of the
Sicilian d6 and Knight to d5 everything
exactly the same as the players already
played Knight captures pawn captures and
here is where Coulson goes into a
different line here every time cross and
went back but nice to be 8 but here he
goes nice to e7 it's a move that's
played not as often as Knight B it is
the main line now but still of course it
is very playable Khurana of course he is
prepared for this move as Knight be
eight and ninety seven are basically the
only two moves that cousin has available
here he goes c4 improves the defense of
the d5 pawn and also if the knight has
to retreat to c3 also you will already
have c4 played we have Knight to g6 by
cross and now comes the Queen to a4 here
we have Bishop to d7 by Carlsen a Queen
to d7 doesn't work as nice to see seven
immediately wins the game I are in check
you cannot capture the Queen is pinned
and if you move the King
remove the king then a queen trade
appears and then you will lose the
exchange after night capture Sunday 8:00
but after Queen captures on a four we
have Bishop to d7 and here we have Queen
to b4 by Caruana we have Bishop to f5
and now comes h4 sorry by Carson and h4
by Caruana and this is a very
interesting moment in the game here this
game was already played it was played in
2018 in the in the Batumi chess olympiad
kramnik had a disposition against her
Ghana which and in that game kramnik
also played h4 where and then a6 was
played and after a six we had a retreat
we had h5 and then after Knight f4
Knight c3 and in the end kramnik was
able to win this game but here after h4
cross and prepared a new move and that
new move is h5 not allowing this pawn to
advance to h5 and now karana has to make
a choice here I will mention this but
after we see a couple of moves by corona
we will return the disposition for a
very specific reason here Caruana
actually played the Queen to a4 he wants
to retreat he wants to repeat a position
here just to see perhaps if course and
is interested in repeating moves but
also to see if if there's anything else
to be played but also perhaps the show
that he if he wanted to he could make a
draw here here across and simply repeat
the Bishop to d7 we have Queen to b4 and
Bishop retreats to f5 so here karana
definitely has to make a decision if he
retreats with Queen to a4 it is very
likely that Carlson will retreat Bishop
to d7 and we will have a draw by
repetition there's a lot a lot at stake
for this game it's the it's game 12 if
they draw this game of course they go
into the playoffs as we've already
mentioned but neither of the players
really wants to lose this game as then
there's no chance to bounce back you you
just lose and whoever loses will again
has to have to go through the candidate
cycle to be able to challenge for the
World Chess Championship title in in two
years time so here Caruana
after thinking for some time a place
bishop
- III and this was a surprise to
everyone
and perhaps even to Carlson but Carson
actually doesn't spend a lot of time
here Bishop to Bishop d3 is not one of
the engines top recommendations the
engine will give it the repeating of the
position between two a4 with the g3 and
also with Bishop to g5 but we're gonna
mention Bishop to g5 a little bit later
as it's it's really an important piece
of evidence for this game Bush up to e3
was played by Khurana and here cross and
spent a little bit of time not too much
and he decided to go for a six and he
finds an excellent idea how to reach a
position for which he was prepared but
through a different move order with
Knight to c3 and now comes Queen to c7
this was a very nice move that you
really had to be prepared for as there
are a lot of ideas to be you know to
watch out for here like Bishop to b6
Knight a 4 to be 694 to - Bishop to b6
so if he plays the Bishop pure then the
Queen can move Queen b7 and now it's not
that big of a problem if the Queen was
on d7 and rockin a8 then Knight a 4
would be troublesome if the knight could
get the b6 in two moves and on the other
hand after Queen to c7 if you go
immediately Knight to a4 then black can
simply go Bishop to e7 and now nice to
b6 I will be met with rook to d8 Queen
a4 check and now you cannot block with
the Queen of course but you can simply
move the king and the king is very safe
on if and f8 at some point you will push
efore here make the room for the night
you will move the knife to e5 this rook
can go h6 and you can bring the rook
over into the game this way black will
be all right here
so here after Queen to c7 Khurana
decided not to do anything rash here
rather g3 was played a very nice move
that prepares to either develop the
bishop differently but most more
importantly takes away the f4 square for
the white for the Black Knight
we have Bishop to e7 and this is the
position cross and had in mind but just
to show you why this position is so
important we will just go back to that
moment where we mentioned that
the g5 was also a possibility it's this
moment here after h5 was played then
Khurana went into this repeating of
moves between a4 and Bishop to e3 Bishop
to g5 is the move that seems to be most
promising here but and of course f6
doesn't really work here Bishop to e7 is
possible but again white would be better
here the best align for black is and
it's actually there there exists a game
in this line that was played between
Houdini and stockfish where Queen to b8
was played here and most likely cousin
was trying to follow this game but it's
interesting here after Queen to b8 white
it doesn't really have a good a good way
to continue again white would have to
play g3 at some point a six would be
played night would have retreat
retreated to c3 and after Bishop to e7
bush of retreats the e3 you will have
this exact same position that was
actually reached in this game but only
be a different move order so returning
back to that position or we said g3
Queen to e7 is played now and now
Caruana decided to go for f3 and again
you can see that Carson is really
prepared and that he was really
following that Houdini stockfish line as
he immediately blitz us out
Knight to f8 when I say blitz is out I
mean he responds in under a minute
we have nice to e4 making room for this
bishop to come to d3 and the knock comes
Knight to d7 here Carlson has a very
nice idea he wants to bring this Knight
over to c5 at some point and from there
he will decide what to do
Bishop to d3 explained by Caruana we
have castles by Carlson and here Khurana
could go for something like castles but
this would be perhaps a bit dangerous
because I have to locate the c8
preparing b5 here you would have to
waste a move you would have to go can be
one to make room for the rook and then
after b5 yes ok now you can play rook to
c1 but that's a lot of moves
so here karana finds a very interesting
idea rook to h2 and also I I haven't
really seen Kasparov say this as I
haven't been following that stream but
someone mentioned it on Twitter that
Kaspar mentioned that this move was a
lot of fun so
just decided to share that as a quote
above the board and it's a lot of fun
because it saves a white a lot of time
here if we go into the same line then
white will be able to castle and then
this rook can come to c2 without this
rook having to waste a move to come to
see one after after this maneuver but
okay Crossing goes rook a to c8 again he
prepares b5 we have queenside castle and
now Carson goes for a completely
different idea he goes Bishop to g6 a
very nice move he prepares f5 here if
you just try and rush it would be five
like we've mentioned then this rook can
immediately come to c2 ended already
counters the Queen rook battery on the C
file after Queen moves pawn captures
pawn captures and after you exchange
here King b1 and white is actually all
right here black can't really push for
for much here
so after queenside castle we have Bishop
to g6 the strongest move recommended by
sesay and f5 is coming so roof to c2 by
Caruana and now Carlsen definitely does
push f5 we have f5 here knife to f2 and
now comes Knight to c5 and here you can
already see that cousins the position is
very strong he has this extremely strong
Knight and c5 the bishops are very
strong this point is coming to e4 at
some point when that happens this bishop
will have this extremely strong diagonal
f6 to a 1 and after b5 comes and the
position opens up it will be a very very
strong position for black here Caruana
plays f4 everyone was expecting Bishop
captures on c5 as that Knight is truly a
tremendous piece here but Khurana played
f4 and here there's a lot of things to
consider consider here Carson said that
he felt that he just had a very very
pleasant position here he could just
push without risking too much here and
he decided to play a 5 it comes as an
attack against caranas queen and he has
to decide what to do with the Queen now
but there was a there was a really a
fancy recommendation by say say I will
just show it even though it's a
supercomputer
but you know just showing it perhaps he
captures on f/4g captures on f4 and now
Bishop captures on h4 so already
grabbing a pawn and now after Bishop
captures on c5 d captures on c5
attacking the Queen the Queen has to
defend the f4 point so Queen to b2 and
now comes Bishop to g3 with a double
attack against the bf4 pawn Knight to h3
and now rook seated d8 we have King to
b1 and now after h4 this is the position
assess ahead in mind where this would be
just cemented here the night would be
stuck here keeping an eye on the f4 pawn
and the black would just have a much
better game here but that's a
supercomputer line better not you know
do well too too long about it and but a
lot of human grandmasters throughout
Twitter and social networks recommended
b5 immediately and it does seem like a
very nice choice after Bishop captures
pawn captures Queen moves now it's a
better position for black black does
seem to be pushing but it's not at all
clear how do you immediately break
through if efore bishop moves back and
it's a I mean if you capture then white
will be able to block the position if
you push through then again everything
will be blockaded so it seems Qasim
wasn't satisfied with this and Caruana
in the press conference I think he
wasn't really he mentioned that he
wasn't too worried about that but okay
after f4 we have a five by cross on a
different idea before his coming at some
point but his idea as he presented it in
the press conference was to push this
pawn all the way to push efore and then
this Bishop from f6 and upon an e3 will
be very powerful and you know create a
lot of harmony and okay
we have Queen to d2 Caruana moves the
queen of course you cannot go Queen b5
it seems like a very nice move blockades
everything but then the shop - eh traps
the Queen so Queen to d2 instead and now
II for Carlson pushes the bishop back
also creates a very nice diagonal for
his own Bishop and now for
he brings this bishop over to e8 and are
also a very important moment where Bush
up to a four is a move that definitely
you have to watch out for as the rooks
are set up the way they are we have King
to be one and now comes the Bishop to f6
still not going for this bunch of tray
for although you do have to always
calculate if after b3 this knife can be
sacrificed for the b3 point we have rook
to e1 getting the root out of this very
nasty diagonal and now comes a move that
Crossin a place
basically he follows his plan but again
we have this I'm just gonna show it
because it's very nice a nice line by
say say that the bishop to a4 was
actually stronger simply attacking the
rook and now after the rook moves for
example rope to c1 you have b5 and after
pawn captures Queen to b6 already it's
only three moves but this line would be
five and Queen to b6 I don't see a human
playing that out putting your Queen in
front of the bishop like this but you're
actually just going after the b5 pawn
and after Bishop to d4 bushell captures
Bishop captures on f6g captures on f6
look to c3 now you will actually just
exchange the bishop on e2 look the Queen
captures an hour to route Knight to a4
you can see what immense pressure black
has now on the King side the rook is
here if the rules get traded of the
other rook will join the attack as well
and the blacks position is just much
more active and this is what says they
preferred but okay after Luke do you
want a for cross someone's to play a
three and then have this very nice
connection here and Queen to b4 this is
a move cross and I mentions that he
missed from Caruana but I mean most
likely if he saw Queen before he would
have gone for Bush up to a four instead
of a foreign this is something he also
mentioned in the press conference when
they asked him about Bishop a4 move he
said that yeah if I didn't if I wasn't
following my own plan it's definitely
what I would have gone for but here just
to show you that there are also some
other dangers in the position if
example if after a for instead of this
white goes for some other plane let's
say Knight to h3 to g5 and such then
there are ideas like Knights to beat the
reef in this exact position it doesn't
work but still it could be very
dangerous after pawn captures pawn
captures now the bishop is still
controlling this diagonal Luke goes back
and now after up to eight white white
will be able to defend with perfect play
as I don't know if something like b5
comes and then rook to a1 becomes a
terrible threat White has this Bishop to
d1 move and he will eliminate this pawn
and then be able to defend and now let's
say b5 now rook to a1 does become a huge
threat as checkmate would very quickly
follow
but after Bishop captures on b3 it's
perfectly fine pawn captures Bishop
captures and white will prevail but okay
just showing you you know some some
poison in the position after a four we
we've said Queen before the move Carlson
said he missed and now comes g6 also if
you go for something like Knights to a6
attacking the Queen then the Queen has
to go back if you try something like
Queen to b6 then after captures and
captures this a3 move will now be very
very strong threatening to open up the
position here it will be it will be very
nice for blacks so but not going for
that g6 was played here and we have rook
to d1 at this point Caruana had 16
minutes on the clock cousin had some 46
minutes on the clock so you know a huge
advantage on the clock as corona still
has to make nine more moves to reach
down control rook to e8 by Carlsen and
interestingly you can we've shown a
couple of very powerful and explosive
variations and it seems to be a very
active game you know it's not like it's
a blockaded position and nothing is
going on which is very strange why it
was in this position and move 31 that
the players agreed to a draw and you can
see that this is something very strange
this is a position where Carlson is just
he has a lot to go for but it seems the
pressure was just too much one okay I
mean you can simply draw and you are the
favorite in in faster time control so it
doesn't make sense for you to draw and
better not make any hasty decisions
today but it's a very strange it's more
31 Khurana still has to make nine more
moves to reach time control he's a very
long clock and there's very little you
can do to actually go wrong but it's
it's a super complicated position so I
guess it kind of does make sense
everyone was saying yeah but what if it
that it you know a draw is a fine
decision because if Bishop to d4 it's
already I mean it's basically already a
draw but not so much Bishop to d4 I
managed to catch and analysis of this
move by CSA and it seems that Carson
said that if Bishop to d4 was played in
the press conference and then he would
either capture or decide what to play
them but actually it seems that Knights
the d3 is the way to go again because
now if you capture it for example bushel
characters on d3 Bishop captures on d4
black keeps the dark square bishop and
after a bishop moves the bishop moves to
c5 black will just be better here with
his bishop pair white didn't achieve
anything with this and if instead after
this Knight to b3 you don't capture you
go something like Queen to b6 as the
Queen is undefended on c7 then we have a
very nice queen capture some b6
capture some b6 and now after night the
before your rockin c2 is under attack as
you can see here and then after the rook
moves a3 comes you have to do something
and Bishop to b2 will snatch the rook so
a very interesting position where well a
lot of players were saying that Bishop
to d4 is excellent and the white
equalizes it would actually be basically
a losing move for white but yeah
I mean it's a very difficult to grasp
this that they actually agreed to a draw
here as there's so much to play for but
there's too much at stake and they were
simply I mean karana was of course very
satisfied with the draw as
he was worse the entire game basically
and he got caught out of preparation but
this is something that you can really
see that what what top level chess is
today basically memorization of
supercomputer moves and then at some
point to you get out of preparation then
you have to start using your own brain
and it was similar to that in the olden
days where you would read a book and
then know a lot of lines but those lines
were also human lines and here it just
feels that there's a too big of a
difference between playing supercomputer
preparation and then after you start
using your brain and then then the
quality seems to drop dramatically which
is normal I mean of course humans cannot
follow that play of a supercomputer but
it's it's it's just I mean you don't
have like this game where someone starts
creating from the start of the game but
rather you have like 25 moves of super
preparation and then the level of play
just drops as I don't think it's the
only problem is that of course humans
cannot play like like computers but you
haven't been playing this game from the
start you just you know you have a
position and then you your opponent
plays a move that's completely out of
your preparation then you have to start
thinking so you have to warm your brain
up first but I'm sure there are
you know our even books maybe even
written about this phenomenon but seems
seems fairly odd but ok I'm basically
just rambling on now at this point this
is game 12 they agreed to a draw now
there will be a rest today and on
Wednesday that's two days from now we
will have playoffs first we will have
four games of rapid that's 25 minutes
for each player with an increment of 10
seconds and if all those games are drawn
then we go into blitz games we will have
5 mini matches so first we have a mini
matter of two games to blitz games and
then if someone wins that match it's all
over if not then we have a second mini
matter of two blitz games third mini
metric to blitz games fourth mini match
and fifth match double its games are
played with five minutes sorry five
minutes on the clock
I believe sorry I have this written down
somewhere but I believe it's yeah five
minutes plus three seconds increment and
if that ends in a draw then we have a
final game 11th game that will be
Armageddon where where black will get
some wear black will have four minutes
and white will have five minutes on the
clock but white has to win that game if
black draws then black wins the title of
world champion 2018 so that's basically
it a really crazy game I'm sure if it
wasn't played in a World Chess
Championship match it would have ended
differently it would have been played
differently you know Carlsen basically
just played a line where he can't lose
and you know if a chance presented
itself then he would take it but he will
not push for anything which makes sense
so what do you think about this whole
phenomenon and this game this match the
time formats be everything you know feel
free to share your thoughts in the
comments below I would like to thank
Steve shankin Michael Ventura antique
opponent another celeb and Samuel Taylor
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content tomorrow we're
gonna check up on some of your own
suggestions and when they were back with
the playoffs thank you all and I will
see you soon